To solve this problem, the first thing I did was say, okay, well,
it looks like this is directly in the middle of this building--this spire.
I can draw some imaginary line, making this distance 25 m.
Now, you could have used trigonometry to solve this question.
But there was a trick.
You could have solved it in a slightly easier way by using similar triangles.
To use the similar triangle method,
we notice that this triangle in purple is similar to this triangle in green.
Now, what are the dimensions of this green triangle?
Well, at 60 m along the base from here, and 15 meters here--
simply because this height is 60,
and we subtract the 45. What about the purple triangle?
Well, the base is 180 m--60 + 35 + 60 plus this 25.
The height is unknown.
This is what we're solving for. I'm going to erase our man to give ourselves some room.
We can set up a ratio.
The ratio of this side to that side must be the same as x to 180.
We multiply both sides by 180 to solve for x.
When we do out the arithmetic, we find x = 45 m,
but we also have to add in the original 45 m to get the full height of the Duomo.
The answer is that the height of the Duomo is 90 m. Very good work.